[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
talk some college football espn.com
senior writer espn insider national
college football reporter heather dinoch
is a senior writer for espn covering
college football and coverage of the
2021 college football season kicks off
this saturday it'll be hawaii at ucla
well that snuck up on me i was wondering
there's always that game in late august
and uh i guess this is the one hawaii at
ucla heather kind enough to join us
heather thanks for joining us explain
what this alliance is
so it's kind of tricky to explain but
the best way i can describe it is the
acc big 10 and pac-12
at some point are going to add a
scheduling component to the way they're
holding hands right and there were no
explicit conversations saying we're not
going to poach each other's teams but
this is a response to the shifting
landscape in college athletics it's not
necessarily a direct response to the sec
becoming the first 16 team super
conference but it's really an alliance
between you'll continue to hear the
phrase like-minded institutions right
there are research universities in those
three leagues that are some of the most
highly regarded and this is a
partnership saying hey let's share our
resources and at some point become
stronger in college football by figuring
out how to work our schedules together
but i'm trying to understand that at
what point you have built-in rivalries
with these conferences uh out of
conference as well
how do you truly
kind of engage these other conferences
so it is
these three conferences combining as one
because we like the sec is not bringing
in the big 12. they just bring in a
couple of teams um that's what i'm
curious about of how how this is really
the inner workings of trying to actually
have a schedule that is conducive to
having this alliance
right and they don't know the answer to
that yet they have not taken a deep dive
on those conversations and part of the
reason for that is the pac-12 still
plays a nine-game conference schedule so
does the big ten right the acc is that
an eight-game conference schedule to the
point you make because they have those
built-in acc sec rivalries you're not
going to lose clemson south carolina
georgia georgia tech etc for the sake of
this agreement so what happens and one
of the other questions too is look if
you fans really want to see ohio state
penn state wisconsin play those big
games right we're not necessarily
talking about an excitement over a
partnership to see wake forest and cal
kick off at 10 pm right
so a question that they have to answer
is well okay if ohio state penn state
wisconsin those brand name schools usc
are the ones bringing in the revenue how
do they share that with the rest of the
league you know those are a lot of
questions that they haven't gotten into
yet but that they will certainly ask
themselves why doesn't the big ten just
reach out to usc
oregon stanford and just say
come on in like we we don't need to take
oregon state or washington state
just kind of pick what like the sec is
doing
that's a fair question um kevin warren
is and we got to remember that we're
talking about three new commissioners
who are dealing with this kevin warren
was hired january 2020 um george
kliehlkoff in the pac-12 came in about
five minutes ago in july and jim
phillips in the acc is a new hire as
well they are navigating this as
extremely smart people and businessmen
but complete rookies when it comes to
the landscape of college football that's
just a reality and and to your point it
wouldn't surprise me if kevin warren and
george did have those conversations and
i think a big reason why the pac-12 is
at least according to sources driving
the push for this alliance is to keep
usc happy keep them from going anywhere
right and so where would they go i don't
know everybody wants to go to the scc
you know who knows but i i can tell you
that sources have said that the push is
coming from the pac-12 to get this done
and part of that is because the tv
contract expires and to keep everybody
happy and in place
also i was told that jim delaney the
former big ten commissioner he's the one
that is behind the scenes here and when
jim delaney gets involved that's when
things get done and you mentioned that
you have rookie commissioners here jim
delaney is is going to lead the charge
here i'm wondering who gets left out uh
you know with the big 12 uh
what what does the big 12 become
so shameless self-promotion here i have
spent all day of reporting what exactly
those eight schools are doing and i'll
have that piece on espn.com tomorrow but
the bottom line is this i mean they're
walking a tightrope between preserving
the big 12 and self preservation and
there is a sense of betrayal again
because they weren't included in these
conversations with the big ten pac-12
and acc and the reason one surmised me
is because they'd already been poached
so there is a hope that this alliance
won't prevent the pac-12 from saying hey
come on over here some leftover big 12
schools but plan a
for them would be to stay together and
try to make themselves whole so that
they could get another lucrative tv
contract but the reality of that is that
slim because they're not going to get
any teams right now from any of those
other four power conferences so you're
looking at maybe the american athletic
conference or the mountain west and does
that give them the value they need to be
a truly vibrant big 12 again
i reported this yesterday that the
alliance will probably try to push off
the expansion because they want to get
other tv networks involved in this not
just let espn dictate this since espn is
in business with the sec as well
that maybe it's 2026 before you have
this
how does the fan benefit in all of this
heather
when you're talking about expansion are
you talking about playoffs
yeah yeah
um so you know ultimately i believe the
college football playoff is going to
expand they have a meeting in late
september and i think that this could
delay it i don't think it's going to
derail it right this skinny minute the
college football fan gets nothing out of
any of this
where's status quo heading into that
hawaii game that you that you just spoke
about um in the long run i think the
college football fan benefits this from
a there's going to be more inclusion in
the college football playoff whether
it's 8 10 12 whatever they wind up
settling on there's going to be more
inclusion i think that's what fans want
to see and two i think you're going to
see better football games there is a
scheduling push i mean regardless of
whether or not you get automatic
qualifiers and conference champions are
in there's still a selection committee
component to this people want to see
good football games and i think
eventually we're going to see more of
that and more inclusion in the college
football playoff but today it means nada
and i've been talking about this for
years where college football is
eventually going to adopt the nfl model
but i'm also wondering about the the
premier league why not have a secondary
conference where you can be
you know
schools get relegated like that you have
really important games at the end of the
year so if you're
iowa state and you're kept out of this
you can move up and then you get a
chance to play i it would add even more
interest drama tension to it because it
feels like we're going to eventually
narrow this down heather to
40 schools
35 schools and those are going to be the
ones that are going to get the money and
you know play for championships players
are probably going to get paid at some
point down the line like i i think we're
they're going to adopt the nfl model
but i'd love to have them adopt the
relegation i think that would be great
what do you think
so what you're talking about is all of
this that happened this summer which is
snowballing into the ncaa constitutional
convention that's going to happen which
is a complete restructuring of the ncaa
how do you do that and that's that goes
in line with exactly what you're talking
about because the night commission which
is like the brains of college sports is
agreeing with you and saying let's make
college football a separate thing
because the reality is it's it's own
thing right and there's the haves and
have-nots and as we talk about this that
gap gets wider and wider i have spoken
to university presidents university
presidents who have said yeah you know
an nfl light model is possible nobody
knows what's going to happen and what
this will look like but this 16 team sec
super conference like that's real what
does it mean and i think time will tell
but i think there's certainly a point
that the ncaa the supreme court a name
image and likeness
you can't rule this stuff out because
it's real and it's happening but it goes
to the restructuring and the governance
of the ncaa and what that looks like
that leaves us with notre dame heather
what does notre dame do
winner winner chicken dinner man they
they
they are so freaky no matter what you
know if i'm jack swarmik the athletic
director at notre dame i am clinging to
my independence because as all of this
moves on around you know they've got it
great and if the playoff expands to 12
teams they're in it more often than not
um so i think that they're in a great
spot i think you know maybe part of this
alliance that we were talking about with
the acc is what can they do to beat
themselves up to try to entice notre
dame to join them full time you know
they got this flirty little thing where
they play a couple games what can they
do to really beef it up they missed the
boat on trying to add texas
um
so is there anything else is this
alliance help maybe but i think notre
dame might be in one of the great spots
and people love to hate it and they're
probably going to continue to do that
does the sec go after anybody else
you know i can tell you that a source at
the presidential level in the sec told
me that we are not sitting here rubbing
our hands together saying who else can
we add
but
if people call us we would be fools not
to listen
[Laughter]
oh okay all right
so we're not poaching but if they want
to be poached then we're open for
business
right i do it's important to remember uh
in the acc their grant of rights which
again is another thing that goes back to
this alliance goes i think their tv deal
is through 2035. so if you're florida
state or clemson and you want to leave
the acc right now you probably have to
pay about 500 million dollars which is
insane that's not to say that it can't
change or be pushed or fought in a
couple years i don't know the answer to
that we you know who knows i'm sitting
here in the state of maryland which
used to be an acc school it's now a big
ten school so they left they got their
exit fee lowered
who knows but
there's a lot of other things that have
to happen for other teams to leave their
own leagues
heather great stuff and uh thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time
my pleasure thank you so much for having
me on heather denich is a senior writer
for espn.com college football kicks off
this weekend
hawaii at ucla let's go i love it